but you know this is what you get from
the Christians like love uh the
Christian and I call them Christian
feminists cuz they're they're basically
just it's very and when I when I say
feminism I'm talking about having asking
men to take on all the burden and
responsibility giving and and not having
Authority and that's what you find with
a lot of Christian feminist I mean I I
triggered all of tradcons by saying you
don't have to ask your wife for anything
CU you should have Authority you know
this is this is crazy um okay so this
Christian woman now threatens me with
God because I asked the question what's
riskier getting a vasectomy or getting
married in 2023 and a lot of times they
don't like these questions because the
answers make women look bad they make us
look bad